wohl zu viele Bergsteiger Filme
angeschaut aber wenn es darauf ankommt
schlapp machen und jetzt sollen mir euch
wieder auf Vordermann bringen
dann dreht sich um
na zur anderen Seiten
nach hinten Sakrament einmal
endlich der original Bayern Smoothie der
schnelle Hausmacher vitamindrink mit
allem was dringend Ausmaß jetzt in der
Sorte radiesel Rettich Blutwurst
[Musik]
und außerdem in der Sorte Blaukraut
Knödel debrezina
[Musik]
und im Geschmack Sauerkraut Gelbwurst
Meerrettich
[Musik]
der original Bayern Smoothie nach
traditioneller Hausmacher Art Bayerns
musst
du Arsche ich muss nur jeder
[Applaus]